being single isn't the easiest thing in
the entire world but it's objectively
better than going to bed besides someone
who uses hope stops breathing in the
middle of the night like just that
disappointment every morning when your
alarm clock goes off and you feel them
move on the other side and you go all
right
another one of those days here she is
mrs breeze through her nose all right
grant another 24 hours in [ __ ] hell
is it no
daniel
in the building how are you doing yeah i
mean in my building
it's an outhouse it's very nice yeah it
is thank you
it was uh built in a panic during a
pandemic to record an audiobook and it's
now used as a masturbatorium
technical term yeah yeah yeah well it
makes it if you just call it like your
jack off room that sounds like dead i'm
classy and i don't think i'd be able to
get away with it but like masturbatorium
makes it seems like i have a you know a
jacket i drink a cognac while i do it
and i've got a monocle in like there's a
community of people that do it with you
and a subreddit and a discord server
yeah yeah yeah yeah we all make sure we
log in at the same time and that's the
look the one thing you can say about the
pentamic is look we all got our own
communities and the massbetorium
membership was one of them have you seen
you haven't seen chappelle's new special
yet
no no i haven't i was too busy watching
um i wanted to and then squid game came
out
and i benched that um i've not watched
the last episode because i can't get
over how [ __ ] appalling
those all the english characters are or
and all the american characters are so
bad man like it's i wonder if like if
this is just like south korean revenge
for the amount of times like we've made
movies and television shows and like we
get people for like playing south
koreans or uh any like you know chinese
or japanese person and we just give them
[ __ ] dialogue because we're translating
it so that's not how they talk and like
to them watching our shows they must be
like man that's not how we sound at all
like this is really [ __ ] and now they've
just shown that done that to us they've
made an incredible tv show and then
every time it's any english speaking
person it's the worst written dialogue
in the world yeah it really does feel
like they're taking the piss you think
it's got 100 on rotten tomatoes at the
moment i think and it's got it's going
to be the biggest show on netflix this
year
and they've decided to give the english
and american people it's like what i
imagine korean people think english and
american people sound like yeah yeah
like it's that it's nice to see us at a
stereotype which is just like
aristocratic
giant wankers obsessed with sex and
talking about how rich they are glittery
heads
yeah yes smoking challenges
from the [ __ ] room like some sort of
king
aren't the poor funny they're part of
the masturbatorium
yes uh they are the masterboard
consortium
yeah that's that's the blend there um so
i watched that and then i watched
[ __ ] um
was that one that's vigil
oh that was good oh really good really
thoroughly enjoyed that and then i'm
gonna get into and getting into
chappelle but i'm also not on social
media uh so i don't see
any of the the council culture or
whatever the [ __ ] is going on yeah so
chappelle's new special
he talks about how
it's the gender debate again like men
and women and he sides with jk rowling
and he says that
turf is
he aligns that with how do you say like
scientific reality or like biological
reality that's saying that men and men
and women are women and [ __ ] like
it's just it went completely bonkers on
the internet and it's got
rotten tomatoes this is one of the
things that's so interesting rotten
tomatoes got a 96 user rating on it but
the critics score hasn't come in and i
think it happened with his last one
where the critic score was like 30
and the the user rating was like 96. so
he just keeps on injecting himself into
these
yeah but i just think it's it's it's
kind of like i always used to really get
annoyed when anyone would go and see
frankie boyle and then still get
offended and it's like man at one point
the responsibilities on you
like if you like if you go to a freaking
ball show and you get offended like what
else were you [ __ ] expecting like the
the contract is signed when you walk
into the room if i'm off to see this
comedian who i know you know is going to
say some horrendous thing because that's
what he does that's why i like him in
the first place that's the [ __ ] i enjoy
about him for the sake he aims that at
me i don't like it so much as anymore um
it's you know i don't agree with
everything chappelle says but i don't
think i agree with anything everything
every comedian says like i i like i'm a
fan of the art of it like i can [ __ ]
separate
um
you know politics and and
personal opinion from just being like
man if you write a joke really well
about my dead sister i'll still [ __ ]
laugh at that joke like i know it's
personal right and i might cry about it
later on but there'll be at least five
minutes where i can appreciate the craft
of what you did that's the problem that
a lot of comedians highlight right that
people are happy for a comedian to take
shots at this group and this group in
this group but as soon as that alignment
happens to be where you sit about
something that you care about then
people decide to get offended
well yeah and i i also get that man it's
very easy to it's much easier to laugh
at someone else than it is to laugh at
yourself laughing itself is very
difficult and i'm still not even [ __ ]
good at it like man i'm a comedian that
preaches you should be allowed to joke
about what you want but that doesn't
mean when my friends insult me i still
don't get [ __ ] precious like being a
human being is complicated and sometimes
their emotions overwhelm muslim we turn
into whiny pieces of [ __ ] but you know
it's to make sure that you don't stand
by those opinions for the rest of the
[ __ ]
uh rest of your life like i will i've
always said i'll defend any comedians
right to say any joke about any [ __ ]
subject but i will also if you tell a
[ __ ] shitty joke and you get booed by
your audience
like i'm also enjoying that [ __ ]
like you tried to push the boundaries
you [ __ ] missed the mark and now
you're getting your [ __ ] comeuppance
it's not cancel culture there's no
difference from doing a [ __ ] it's no
different from doing a joke in a comedy
club that turns the entire audience
against you and they go boo or they
don't like about you you come off you
have a cry you go drive four hours home
you have a wank in a [ __ ] service
station toilet like that's the game when
you get cancelled online that's just
what's happening but coming for like
[ __ ] weirder reasons be like somebody
coming to a new comedy club and yelling
at you for a joke you told eight years
ago that's when it gets a bit you know
shite
there's a quote from your book new book
which people can go and buy and it's
talking about
what i realized was you don't think that
people should have an opinion on
everything which is actually that is
quite a controversial opinion to have so
i don't know what it's like to not feel
comfortable in your own body so asking
me for my opinion on gender fluidity
would be like asking the pope for his
stance on [ __ ] i've got one but it
doesn't really matter sound cowardly it
is i've seen too many good men and women
die in that minefield and i'm not being
paid enough to walk through it with a
[ __ ] blindfold on do you need to have
an opinion on everything
yeah i know i don't think and that's man
i'll stay out of some debate some people
will call it cowardly go man i don't
respect my own opinion on some things
like i know what i know a lot about i i
will argue with anyone about [ __ ]
comedy and the reason that is is i know
more about comedy than 99.9 of the
population because i've watched it
longer i've done it longer i study it
more like it's my obsession i know that
do i know anything about [ __ ] ballet
or poetry get [ __ ] i'm not going to
fight as passionately for who the
greatest ballet dancer but i don't even
give
a [ __ ] but we live in a time now where
you know
everything is so polaroid but
intentionally [ __ ] polarized that you
know people just want an excuse to
[ __ ] hate someone else because hate
feels really good man it's that close to
love and when you're not loved hates a
[ __ ] fun substitute for a lot of
people
and
it's just nice to sort of get
um angry so that's why you know i'm
i i think you can't joke about anything
but just because you can
doesn't mean i would and doesn't mean
you necessarily should like i think
there is a responsibility sometimes to
go right what are you making a joke
about right and why are you making the
joke now you don't have to you're a
comedian i'll defend your right to tell
any joke for any [ __ ] reason for the
sake of a laugh but that doesn't mean i
as it could be i don't have models i'm
still on a moral level going are you
saying that joke just to piss people off
are you saying that joke just because
you like pissing those people off are
you trying to be derogatory and you're
you know it's it's complex um
and
i make sure that
well at least i try to make sure that
when i'm
talking about something i at least
either have knowledge of it and my own
unique opinion on it or i make it very
obvious that i'm aware i'm a [ __ ] and
nothing i say should be taken seriously
that's the safety blanket yeah your
livelihood relies on your ability to say
words though and there's we are having
some words being thrown into different
buckets and you talk about that with
your experience with your sister as one
of you one of the little batches are you
concerned long term about words becoming
taboo or do you think it's like just a
lot of fuss about nothing
um i mean
yeah i mean
i mean i write the word [ __ ] and
[ __ ] in the book people will those are
trigger words for some people and i
respect people
who are triggered by those words i don't
have the same triggers though those
words being different uh things to me if
somebody doesn't like my use of a
certain word and then never wants to
consume my art again i respect that as
an opinion okay i get it but i'm not i
don't need you to be a fan
like that's not what art is i didn't i
didn't create what i do to get you i
created what i do because that's why i
like you can choose to consume it or you
can choose not to and that's the
boundary both artist and consumer forget
a lot of the time because you've got
artists that are obsessed with keeping
their fans you know no no matt you've
changed the gallery like people walk
through they might not come back like
they might enjoy you for a period of
time and that's great and then you grow
and they grow and it would be [ __ ]
insane for you to try and grow with your
audience because that's not what they
want to do they didn't come to you
because you were like them they went to
you because they were like you and if
you diverge at any point hopefully
they're mature enough to be able to go
okay you know i don't agree with what he
says anymore but i still like his style
or i still want to consume some stuff
and oh and i like having another opinion
on my hands or they go you know what i
[ __ ] hate this person now i don't
like you and i don't want to i don't
want to watch your stuff anymore and ask
the eyes you go okay stop fighting for
them they're gone man i went first time
i did like
uh
like real material was when i was about
21. like i'd done four years of the
fringe
and it was when i was doing like loads
of like you know pre-watershed tv like
paula grady and stuff i was tv friendly
not swearing too much my mom's weird my
dad does this blah blah blah
and then
you know i sell out a bunch of shows
during the fringe on that there's like
400 people in a day coming to see me
live and then i start talking about how
there's no gods and i think drugs are
great and i think all religious people
are stupid and every single day i had to
watch
to 30 people leave the room because
they'd come to see what they'd seen on
television they weren't getting that and
they were choosing to and they're not
mad they're allowed to leave
like i had they it was hard to watch man
it was gutting and there was part of me
that was like no no change material and
change you know you have the skill to
keep those people in the room so do it
and then i had to consciously go no
like people are are allowed to not enjoy
your work that's the point if you were
if everyone loved your work you'd be
peter k and peter k is [ __ ]
i suppose as well when you get to the
size of chappelle and you're so
established and you've been in the
industry for so long you can kind of do
what you want you can take the art form
in your own way yeah and also imagine
like it's it's still
every single time there's going to be a
dave chapel special there's going to be
the same
fire one because the media knows that
causes this massive argument so they can
obviously get all the clicks from there
here's the most extreme opinion on this
side here's the most extreme opinion on
this side let's put them together in the
same article and claim that that
represents the audience 50 50. and
you'll get people coming in and
defending it and people coming in and
being like oh does he have to do it
again and all opinions are everyone is
entitled to an opinion
that's a rule but not every opinion is
[ __ ] equal and also people don't have
to respect or even hear your opinion
you're not entitled to have your [ __ ]
opinion heard that's not that's not what
everyone's entitled to an opinion means
you can have one but we don't have to
[ __ ] listen to it i don't know you i
don't care about you shut the [ __ ] up
why would i listen to your opinion right
people listen to my opinion because i've
worked on that for years and years and
years that's why i've got the [ __ ]
goal to tell you my opinion people pay
for it cunn who the [ __ ] are you
seven users watched bull barnum a bunch
of times which is a special i adore by
the way but it doesn't mean you know
more than me [ __ ]
jesus christ all right have you actually
been cited
as one of the causes for a divorce
yeah yeah man actually cited on the
piece of paper
yeah as in like it's like what they like
because oh i mean i don't know i don't
know a lot about a
divorce uh a lot of stuff but like
people have brought the bits of paper
and you know when they've got like
reasons like about what i sign says my
name and the show because you've signed
them yes yeah yeah just autographed them
like it's a copy of their ones that
they're gonna frame for whatever reason
300 divorces 350 cancelled engagements
and more than 120 000 breakups yeah i
mean those numbers are way higher now
but yeah
like they we kept having to update it as
the book went on and then and i stopped
counting a while ago uh just because i
mean i came off of most of social media
so there was just no way to do it so
they're
like the i mean the breakups are an
estimate we stopped counting the
divorces then we still but we still get
messages through man i'll still get at
least one a week
you're like the [ __ ] harbinger of the
breakup apocalypse i liked it people
could have called jigsaw like the ring
but for toxic relationships
like that once you watched it yeah it's
like and again look it's it's never
broken up a good couple like nobody's
i'm not a magician
like there was no there was no two
parents together they'd been together
for 25 years you know their eldest was
16 they decided what and they loved each
other so much high school swears and
then they watched my stand up and by the
end they were like i hate you this is
over you can keep the kids i never let's
never happen it's people in shitty
relationships watch this special and
they look at their subpar partner and
they go oh
i could and i do deserve better than
this
how would you advise someone to go
through breaking up with a partner then
or how should people work out if they
need to break up it's a difficult
question
a very difficult question and it's a and
the cop-out answer is the true one which
is only you'll know
and but what is also true is sometimes
you don't know sometimes you're sort of
loaded in your relationship and you're
so scared of the other side because
you're so terrible at being alone that
you've got this thing of like even if
this is [ __ ] it's better than nothing
and that's never true by the way like no
relationship is always better than a
[ __ ] relationship like being single
isn't the easiest thing in the entire
world but it's objectively better than
like going to bed besides someone who
uses hope stops breathing in the middle
of the night
like just that disappointment every
[ __ ] morning when your alarm clock
goes off and you feel them move on the
other side and you go [ __ ] all right
another one of those days
here here she is mrs [ __ ] breathe
through her nose all right grant another
24 hours in [ __ ] hell is it no
like when you start feeling that way
it's probably time to because the reason
i broke up with my ex was because i wish
she was dead and that wasn't because she
deserved to die but i'm like man the
second i want you to die or the second i
don't want to give you all of myself you
deserve better as well man it's like you
gotta remember if you're in a
relationship you don't like the other
person you owe it to them not to waste
their [ __ ] time anymore like breakups
are always hard right we know there
because there's no perfect way to do
them i mean there were i don't know what
was wrong with texting but apparently we
all had a vote
and
texans just snarling i don't get i don't
get why it's just so efficient it's over
no you don't need an expert come on [ __ ]
it's done who cares but all right we had
a vote and morally it's wrong i see i
got it
um
you know it's gonna suck for um
a long time and every second you don't
break up with them it's like time within
that person and your own you know
healing
that you're robbing them from like i
think if you're not allowed to text them
what's the
what's the optimal way to try and get it
done because it's difficult you've got
this thing you want to do you're talking
to a person you're terrified of being on
your own you don't want to hurt them you
don't want to hurt yourself it's like a
it's the perfect cocktail to not make a
decision yes i and then there's also the
the anxiety and especially if you are in
a toxic relationship which is the ones i
encourage people to get out of you've
always got that fear in the back of your
head whether it's valid or not that the
other person is going to do harm to
themselves or others if they're in a
heightened saddened emotional state and
the
brutal truth of it is you are not
responsible for other people's feelings
and emotions and or their actions and
it's nice to feel it's don't give up
it's a nice thing to
feel that concern for other people
that's empathy don't lose that it's not
a matter of not being empathetic but
it's a matter of understanding where
your responsibility to somebody else
like like them keeping you in a
relationship because you're worried that
they'll hurt themselves that's not a
good situation uh to be in so i mean
make sure that when you do it that
they're not you've not isolated them
like don't don't go on holiday with them
and then be like hey
guess what it's [ __ ] over thanks hey
thanks for coming to where i live just
to let you know it's over day one i know
you fly back in a week but hopefully you
can get over it scotland's beautiful
have a walk like that's not a kind way
to do it do it a place where you know
they can get support afterwards
and where you can um
but yeah i mean do get out of it
as soon as you as you [ __ ] can like
why why waste a second it's oddly
narcissistic to think about the effect
that you breaking up with someone has on
them because people think it's empathy
but it's not it's narcissism it's the
belief that without me how could you go
on i mean i i'm i'm so fantastic i'm
obviously your entire world yeah your
life before me was essentially just one
big warm-up routine awaiting my arrival
now the king or the queen is here and
you're just going to be this slobbering
mess on the floor this grey goo how are
you ever gonna get a better deck than
this i'd kill myself too if i were you
and i was losing this i'd be gone that'd
be the end of me so yeah i mean that is
what it is
[ __ ] man what about people that
break up i think you talk about this in
the book people that want to break up
because they have the allure of novelty
of being single again and just wanting
to [ __ ] lots of people well i think
that's i mean i've always said the
number
what i believe the number one cause of
breakups and divorce later on in life is
curiosity which is like you know
um
this
let's let's
be true love is brilliant and it's what
we all should be looking for in life but
we should always looking for it in its
truest form just because we're so
desperate to find the real thing doesn't
mean we should buy a knockoff one other
way or sell for a [ __ ] knockoff one
love is really really
uh brilliant to expect in fact i've
rambled so much i've forgotten the
questions go again
they were talking about whether people
should break up because they want to
[ __ ] lots of different people oh well i
mean should is an interesting way to
phrase it but yeah like you do get if
you if you fall in love in high school
man when you've got no other
love to compare it to like you do and
you stay together all that time and you
have kids early on because that's part
of the plan there will be a point when
you're 30 or 40 and you've been with
this person for 15 years where you just
get curious and it's not in like i think
i'm going to do well but it's you just
don't know your friends aren't in
relationships one of them goes through a
divorce or you're just so used to this
is your new normal now that you know now
that your kids are teenagers you can
slow down a bit
and suddenly you're a different person
than you were several years ago of
course you are because you've gone
through this and also the person you're
with is a different person because
you've all gone through these changes
now hopefully you grow uh together and
sometimes you don't but you can still
learn to be with each other
during that but you
get this idea of like oh man if i was
single i'd be [ __ ] great at like oh
man i'd i'd i'd be this i've got this
and it's all a lie it's all this
illusion in our heads that you know
we i used to have a joke about it on
stage that i could never get working
which was like when you're in a
relationship and you picture being
single you're like a lion that's been
raised on a zoo like and it's just
you're behind the bars and you're
looking at all the human joint man if
these bars weren't here i get every one
of you i'm the [ __ ] king of savannah
i'd move you all [ __ ] down in reality
if you were to drop a caged lion who
grew up in a zoo in the savannah it
would be dead in three [ __ ] hours
it's never had to hunt for meat it had
zookeepers just bring it out like it
would die it would be it would be killed
by a [ __ ] gazelle
would just run into the side of it and
it wouldn't know what to do and it would
whimper and die like that's people in
relationship but i think they just took
that as a massive insult and they didn't
like the joke the grass is always
greener with this stuff man and i think
yeah so many people that are in
relationships that have been in them for
a very very long time
they don't know what single life is
actually like like i'm not talking about
the idealized top 5
of being single the
excitement of speaking to someone and
not knowing if you're going to get it on
and then they're going back to the house
and the taxi ride where you're fumbling
around in the back on the way there and
being told by the taxi driver to stop
doing that you can't do that in here
mate and like that's
fun but the wake up the next day with
the hangover and the existential angst
the constant feelings of insufficiency
and insecurity about whether or not this
person does like you the [ __ ] time
the tar oh my
dear lord the amount of time on whatsapp
or on [ __ ] instagram or whatever
yeah and i bet that and then all the
loneliness as well i mean like being
single is a lot of time and you have to
if you've been in a relationship for 15
years [ __ ] you ain't good at
being alone i know it's alluring to you
but go on a fishing trip like you're not
ready for real alone like that's what
you that's why people get into
relationships is because they're so bad
at being alone
the other one is the
is the is the safer option for them but
um
i i always think when people are do get
that curiosity of like i wish i was
single i'm like man understand though as
well on the other side you've got people
out here in the single game wishing
they'd been in relationships for 15
years wishing they had that emotional
connection with someone in that life
journey like it's all about
uh perspective and whatnot but it's also
why i feel very secure in my
relationship because
like i'm i'm very in love with my fiance
she's uh wonderful we've been together
for four and a bit uh years now but
before her i lived a life man
like i'm not i'm not getting curious
when i'm 45
like
i i did it it was it was fun uh it's not
me anymore but
um like i always wanted to settle down
and have kids like that was always part
of my uh plan i love children and i i i
just i've always wanted to be a dad but
i always knew
that you know that was the when you
start that chapter if you do it right
the goal is for that to be forever you
don't want to do it multiple times uh
best case scenario is it's hard for the
rest and to do that i had to make sure
that i wasn't going to be curious i had
to make sure that when i was 50 no part
of my brain was like i wonder what a
threesome is like i had to make sure i
knew dude i've got a friend who's big
into pick up artistry and i was talking
to him years ago about this and i was
like man like you
put in a lot of graft with women like an
unforgivable amount of time that you put
in he's like yeah dude my future wife
better thank me for all of this time and
effort i'm putting in that's right
please elaborate to me on how your
future wife should be so thankful that
you've sprayed it around for the last
decade of your life he's like well i
don't ever want to be walking down the
street with my misses and our two kids
and look at a brazilian girl and think i
want to know what it's like to [ __ ] a
brazilian girl i want to have done it i
want to have ticked off every single one
of the different sexual kinks that i've
got because closing those loops gives my
future wife the best opportunity for us
to make it work i'm like well that that
might also
the other way around man like i'm like
i'm glad my fiance lived a [ __ ] life
before me man like would be i find
jealousy one of the most insane things
in a relationship especially this
jealousy of your partner's previous
actions before you like i'm a big
believer in the second we get into a new
relationship if unless it's murder or
pedophilia you've got to forgive me for
everything i did before this second
because i didn't know you existed before
this like all of that don't get me wrong
is a fair representation of my character
and i will always you know you have to
stand by your actions even the bad ones
you and you admit why they were [ __ ]
wrong but like
you know my fears i've i write about it
in the book and this was when i wasn't
with my
fiance i think i
uh wrote that i really hope she was out
there in the world sucking dick right
now because i want her to be
good at and i want her to not be curious
when i when we're older together of
course i wanted her to live her [ __ ]
life every time she talks about like you
know we're very open in our relationship
it's about you know past conquests and
stuff and man i'm proud of her because i
wasn't there and it's nice to know that
like man i got like i got a good one
this is like finding out that you killed
a general like this is
like i
i took one of the goats out of the game
[ __ ] this is cool
matt if you retire michael jordan come
on you gotta that's a badge
what's your thoughts on tinder
oh i loved it back when it was good
back when there was the
the golden era of tinder what was that
uh before all the losers [ __ ] found
it tinder was this whispered secret
promise
of this app which is there's a there's
an app just for hiccups and you were
like what what no way there's no way
that's true and like it's just
like-minded people because before it was
like plenty of fish uh which is a dating
one i've done that when i was single but
i always felt that felt bad because
there's a dating website and i was i'm
like i don't want to date yeah like i
was also designed and looks very much
like if
the sunday sun made a dating site i know
that aesthetics and user experience
isn't everything but i want you know
tinder feels at least it felt a little
bit more slick
yeah it did and it felt good and it was
just and it was so
shallow and it was just so openly
shallow like it was just yeah man you
can read about them but like let's not
kid ourselves what the first law is
like and you just swiped and like it was
a very different experience for men and
women and i know that i'm getting it
from the perspective of like when it fit
i was a zed list [ __ ] straight white
man on it right so i'm not getting the
level of abuse that like women are
getting on but this was again before all
that happened this was still the
exciting times and i remember just being
worried because like everyone was like
it's just a hookup website i'm like oh
god i don't know how to
i don't think i know how to just hook up
with someone like like i normally like
date and then build up to it like what
do we do and then i was in australia and
like
match with a girl on it we went out for
a couple of drinks and it like it was
hard after like four hours it was like
should we go bang and i was like
huh
and she was like yeah like you want to
go because it's on tinder and i'm like
oh all right yeah oh great and i'm like
man this is i was like it's grinder
because i've got gay friends and grinder
was just this promised land of like hey
i've got a button that gets me sex
whenever i want it because it's an app
of like-minded horny [ __ ] men and it
felt like we'd got that we had a great
night and then i remember like the
morning afterward i asked her in the
morning i went can i have your number
and she just went
why
you don't live here i'm not coming to
scotland and i was like
oh my god
yeah i couldn't [ __ ] believe it and
then like she kissed me goodbye and i
was like can i
come see you later she's like no go it's
done i was like oh my god and like that
was tinder from my experience like
whenever i went to america and
the uk and stuff was just i would keep
meeting uh
women who were just very similar along
the lines of hey let's get here for
three days let's have fun for three days
you know it's like the perfect i always
argued that was like the perfect
uh what a relationship it's you get
three days of all the last all the
attraction and all the sex but without
them learning all of your flaws without
you learning all of their flaws and in
the future like you know 20 years down
the line when she's married and have
kids and she's having a rough day she
can fondly reminisce to the time that we
were in denver colorado together she got
her head back
yeah you know through a headboard by uh
by a comedian and then i can look back
and it's this perfect memory you know in
in in the past and then
you start getting all the [ __ ] you
know and then everyone started finding
out about tinder and then you start
getting all the
i'm not here for a one night stand [ __ ]
and you're like get off the [ __ ] half
then
this is the one night stand up you
[ __ ] [ __ ] how [ __ ] we were having
these are our people this was our place
you have come into our sacred place and
you've ruined it yeah yeah and i know
men ruined that i know it was i know it
was my [ __ ] team being creepy and
weird and like you know there was a
golden time when it was just all the fun
people it was like raya you ever heard
of [ __ ] raya no oh right so right oh
let me tell you about this it's the
famous tinder right there's a celebrity
tinder okay right so you've got to be
like [ __ ] verified on i think it's
like twitter and instagram and episode
and you've got to like send them your
profile and they decide if you're
verified to get on yeah yeah ria all
right whitney comments told me about to
put a recommendation jesus they told me
no
i've never
told me about it like six or seven years
ago like
um
and and i was adding and it's like man
it's better it's celebrity tinder so
it's like they're it's just they're
awesome
kardashian tonight do i fancy a cummings
do a fantasy or whatever [ __ ] hell
yeah oh god jesus christ there are a lot
of mp's on
in the female section
strange all right so given the fact that
you're very happily engaged now yes
do you
look back on jigsaw
in a different light and in your thought
process around jigsaw uh differently or
no
and it's
the thing that annoys me is the amount
of people who the man i get it like i
know it's a joke most of the time when
people call me a hypocrite like it's
it's the joke i'd [ __ ] make like i
get it
but
at a purely a personal whiny level i'm
like i'm not a hypocrite jigsaw was
never
i never once said love wasn't real the
whole point was it definitely exists and
that's what i was after it was meant to
be the whole point was you know i kept
forcing myself into relationships
because i was so desperate to be in a
relationship because that's what i
thought i had to do
i would compromise myself so much in
relationships because that's what i've
learned relationships were about what
about sacrifice and about sacrificing
part of yourselves for the greater good
of this relationship so you and this
person can be together forever and then
just you know settling and giving up and
you know compromising your own happiness
for the sake
of
the
the great good night and i didn't i was
like that's [ __ ] like i don't i
refuse to believe that's what a
relationship is that's what i've done so
many times and i've hated all those
relationships so now i'm going to i'm
going to make sure that in the future
you have to love 100 of who i am and
that was all thank you like you have to
truly love me for all of me and i have
found someone like that don't get me
wrong it's weird like you think you want
it and then you find somebody who
actually loves 100 of you and you're
like oh you're [ __ ] up
like that like you shouldn't you
definitely shouldn't love all of me like
there are now that you love all of me i
guess i do kind of have to admit that i
am a flawed person and maybe you
shouldn't love those flaws because if
you love them i'll not improve them and
it would be nice to you know i only hold
my hold myself to a certain level uh but
because i love you more than i love
myself it would be nicer for you to but
you know carry me up and
um but even then i i think she she just
wants the best for me and she as long as
i'm happy she's happy and that is
exactly the type of relationship i was
yelling about
and and the one that you should settle
for like the whole thing was she is bet
for me she's better than being single
and that was i was like yeah being
single was so much fun for me that if
you were going to get me into a
relationship it had to be [ __ ] better
it had to be no and the second it
stopped being better than being single
i'm out that [ __ ] relationship
because the other thing is good i'm
always going to go for what makes me
happier now definitely happier than i
was when i was single consistently all
the time um not been any the only
arguments we've ever had so far is when
i'm being the psychopath
and that was just like during the
pandemic and that was a narcissist going
from all the attention in the world to
none of it so it was just some
adjustments on my side some people use
that lack of love from the other side
it's like a
that's an attractive quality or like
elements that the other side pulls away
you know when people get too keen or
when people do begin to love 100 of you
you can actually start to pull away from
that because you think hang on if i
don't fully love myself and this person
does [ __ ] there must be something wrong
with them which means that i shouldn't
be in a relationship with them it's so
bizarre that the thing that we've wanted
all along which is for someone to accept
us for our flaws you know warts and all
successes and all to support us through
good times and bad when someone does do
that because we have such an inherently
poor own self-image we actually get
turned off by that yeah yeah and i but i
think you can get beyond that you just
have to acknowledge that's what is
happening
there what is that is somebody's truly
loving
you for who you are
it's
it's not a lack of it it's not a bad
thing on their part you should use that
to go right they do love who all of i am
and i love them so much i should be
better because i want to [ __ ] bar it
i don't want to make them love a piece
of [ __ ]
like i don't mind my own like we could
all hate our own reputation but if i'm
just walking around looking like [ __ ]
smelling like [ __ ] and they still love
me that's very irresponsible of me like
i should be making them you know they're
always going to be proud
yeah but i should be doing my best to
make sure that other people are going
have you seen what she's let him get
away with
like he's chat he's a beast now he's a
smelly decrepit beast i can't and no she
still loves him she says his heart's
good apparently yeah [ __ ] weird
another thing is when people if you fall
quite hard for someone if you love
someone very quickly or if you're
spending a little bit of time the same
thing can happen if you get too keen too
fast
the amount of game playing i think this
is something that i struggled with a lot
during my 20s because i wanted to be
loved like i really really wanted i'm
quite an affectionate person which i
think that you are as well like i just
really really wanted to be loved and
have an emotional connection with
somebody and what it leads to is you
your emotions end up being
further ahead of how you're displaying
your emotions to the other person so
like your emotions are moving at a
thousand miles an hour and you're like
right yeah but i need to pump the brakes
on what i'm actually texting this person
or saying to them in front so you end up
playing this like weird reserved game
version of you because you know if you
come on too strong too fast this
person's going to go away yeah trying to
decode each other's messages like where
like i
i don't know like there's so many things
i did love about being single but man it
was stressful that boys are like is this
the right thing to how long should i
wait to reply should i wait like is the
is is this is this too forward like i
don't want to make this person
uncomfortable but is it not or is it not
forward enough like have i made and also
have i made sure that like you know
uh if it is just a fling i'm after it
they know that that's what the goal is
and i'm not like yeah i'm not tricking
someone to i'm not making someone feel
like i'm after a relationship like i'm
not giving them mixed signals but let's
also make sure that i'm not getting
[ __ ] mixed signals like like me let's
make sure i'm making it edits yeah a
whole bunch it's a [ __ ] minefield man
like this is the thing this is the thing
for the boomers out there office someone
that's been in a relationship for ages
that's looking at tinder and [ __ ]
only five you would be [ __ ]
every single one of you wouldn't last a
[ __ ] second it would be like signing
up to the army now you decrepit old
[ __ ] you'd be shot dead by a sniper you
didn't even know was on the field
like it would just it would be a [ __ ]
drone strike and you're over like i yeah
none of you none of you if you're over
40 it's over okay have you seen those
memes and it's where everyone's in the
church and they're sat and everyone has
got a gun behind them and then there's
another frame of a sniper up on a
rooftop and there's another frame of
another sniper up on a rooftop yeah it's
like that man you uh you talk about
having a child having license and this
is something like this is the most bro
signed thing ever my dad's been saying
this like for as long as i can remember
i can't believe that you have to get a
license to drive but all of these idiots
have had children without one yeah yeah
not even not even other people i include
myself in that [ __ ] list i like i do
not think
i think it's the greatest oversight in
humanity now that we just let anyone
preach as much as they want and i
include myself in that there should be a
point where i
you know have to pass certain tests and
uh in order to have kids because some
people aren't fit to be parents and then
some people who want to be who are fit
to be parents can't be on the other side
so you've got all these people that you
know for fertility reasons they would be
wonderful parents but they just [ __ ]
can i i think we need to level the game
and also that's a very like close
that's one of the bits of the book where
on stage i know how to make something
very obviously a joke right and it's and
it's easier because you can be more
subtle on stage it's the twinkle in an
eye it's the tone of voice
it's that little bit of like [ __ ]
prolonged eye contact the legs of the
audience no wink wink i'm just gonna say
something horrible here and that's the
joke itself
uh i don't know how it comes across in a
book
like there's so many bits in that book
where i'm like if you just read that
straight out like i
[ __ ] i can't read that book
without hearing it in your accent i
challenge anybody
to read that book without hearing it in
a broad scottish accent i believe but
for people that don't [ __ ] know me i
i i bought the book then
they bought a book called everybody you
know is going to die because what
because it was on [ __ ] the w.h
smith's counter in the airport and they
thought oh i'm off the way to
menorca i'd better get i better get
myself a nice light read it's between
dan brown and daniel sloss
i won't bother with the new [ __ ]
yeah
angels and demons
[Laughter]
yeah i i agree but it's just one of
those in a in a time of click-bait
culture and you know just people trying
to sell
stories but you could very easily
there's so many bits in that joke where
you could just sorry
there's only this in that book where you
could just take out a context and that's
and start a good fire i mean but
thankfully i'm i'm not on twitter
therefore i am absolutely [ __ ] immune
completely immune yeah what uh why did
you call it that why is it why is that
the name
that was actually the publisher's uh
choice because i couldn't think of
any title and also i hate
uh this is gonna there's gonna be an
accidental slam on some people i don't
mean it to be but like
if you're a comedian and you're writing
a book or a tv show and your name is in
the title
you narcissist like well i it happened
when i was 18 i had a pilot for the bbc
called everyone oh no what was it it was
all the adventures of daniel
like just because bbc were so obsessed
with getting my [ __ ] name and i'm
like just call it anything it doesn't
matter people know who i am like the
name doesn't have to be this isn't
seinfeld where you go why is it called
oh
like
uh and so they were like just call it
daniel slaughter's book was then puns on
on that i might keep my name should only
be on the [ __ ] side of it um and i
don't want it to be any sort of promise
i don't want it to be
eh
well i don't want the book the title to
be any unfulfillable promise like i'm
gonna fix your life i'm gonna make you
feel better i'm gonna do this and it was
just it's one of the lines in the book
which is one of the rants i have where
is
like we pretend that death is a bad
thing even though it gets rid of like
all the bastards like something like
death is really sad when somebody you
love dies but like why are we pretending
for a second that there are some people
on this planet who every second they've
been on this planet have tried to make
it a worse place and knowingly made a
worse place for their own [ __ ]
prophets when those people die it is
objectively [ __ ] good objectively
equal opportunities employer yes yeah
yeah man i've got two balls of champagne
that i bought several years ago and on
the sides of those bottles of champagne
are the names of two celebrities who
will remain nameless
but the day they [ __ ] die and it's
not going on instagram it's not it's not
for anyone else apart from me but when
they [ __ ] die pop
[Music]
some
and that's a good thing i love when bad
people die that's the best bit about
movies that was the best bit about game
of thrones when bad people you hate die
great
how do you deal with death because
you've dealt with a little bit of it i'm
yet to have anyone close in my family
die how do you deal with it um i mean
not well nobody deals with it well
that's the the problem oh well no here's
everyone deals with it as well as they
can but there's no perfect way to deal
with it there's no
um
i might as well say there's no right and
wrong way there's definitely wrong ways
what's the wrong way
oh you know taking out on an entire
group of people and killing them uh
blowing killing yourself deciding that
it's not worth it anymore uh becoming an
alcoholic becoming a drug addict you
know you know
doing things
that are
you know not
better not steps towards getting over
the grief but sometimes steps towards
getting over the grief look unusual to
people not grieving
uh and and because people grieve in
different ways you'll get a lot of
people so you shouldn't do that like for
so many people and this is
understandable where they can't or don't
want to laugh after death which is man
forget it grief is this overwhelming
ball around you that you're just in and
and sometimes like laughter just feels
disingenuous or even cruel at that point
but to other people it's the [ __ ]
life raft it's the it's the one it's the
bit that reminds them in the group
to laugh in the face of grief is one of
the most defiant things in the [ __ ]
world and it's truly the only way to
beat it for for me personally the only
time i've ever come out i've truly come
out of sadness and the moments where i
know i'm sick the moments when i know
i'm doing better or when i'm laughing
and man when you're drowning you don't
care what it is that's keeping you
afloat like sure you get up there and
you're like oh [ __ ] this is 19 babies
tied together i really wish 19 babies
tied together weren't keeping me afloat
like this is objectively evil and a bad
thing but i'm not drowning anymore oh
let me go over to this other thing
that's flowing because i don't want to i
don't want to be careful oh god it's a
bunch of pensioners it said okay and
these are alive like is it morally
better to like be floating because of a
bunch of dead babies or is it better to
to like flip them over and then like you
know
just keep their head above water
um and
people want to be grief police uh
they want to tell you that you shouldn't
laugh at these things that like that
jokes about dead people are
disrespectful you go only if the dead
person when they were alive says that's
disrespectful understand when i die open
[ __ ] season on me for everyone i'm a
comedian right i want to [ __ ] die the
way i live you made fun of me when i was
alive make fun of me when i'm dead cut
this [ __ ] clip out and let people let
them [ __ ] roast me say the worst
[ __ ] things so and and so in the
future what i'm doing
nobody's being disrespectful by laughing
at me because that's what i wanted my
life to be was to make people laugh so
in my death i want to make people laugh
i don't want oh i've always said my
funeral what i wanted to be
is every single person in my life going
up on stage and telling the worst story
about me like just a time when i was
rude a time when i was selfish
a time when i was maybe cruel uh or or
or forgetful or unfor unforgiving and
just all these of everything so just by
the end of the funeral people go
oh maybe it is good like maybe
now that i now that i've heard those
like
you've got a group of people at the back
of the room that have all pop bottles of
champagne
[Laughter]
he's [ __ ] gone [ __ ]
i i'm not against any of that
if you can laugh at my [ __ ] funeral
that's because also i want because man
and i
like as the narcissist we would say
before like you know when you break up
with someone you imagine you've ruined
their life and there's no recovery
we do get the same narcissism like man
when i'm dead how will the world go on
how will how well they christopher this
will you live without me
[ __ ]
with glee my friend
and for many years i get the impression
given the lifestyle that you've gone
through hi
oh god yeah yeah yeah yeah we finally
the other day when we were in them
we were in estonia uh and just the
comedians out there it was the first
time i've ever had this compliment it's
a compliment we've always known we were
worthy of but it's one we've just never
been given and it was just one of the
other guys being like man like we
genuinely don't understand how you two
are the way you tour like it's just
like it nobody else does it like that we
were like good good right just as long
as we're aware that we are
we are the only rock and roll comedians
truly left what's that mean
um well i mean
uh we were so well at least for me when
i was younger i was so desperate to you
know be a touring comic and you build up
in your head that you go out and you you
know you drink and you party and you and
live these lives so there was times when
we were
like at least
me and kai's [ __ ] first tour
we were so desperate because we're like
we're on a 60-day tour like 50 dates
over 60 days
and
we would go out drinking on a tuesday in
banbury after playing to 25 [ __ ]
people like let's go out let's try and
get laid and we're like man just go to
[ __ ] bed what are you doing
on a wednesday both sharing a travel
lodge and then we'd be in the car park
downstairs smoking weeds just hot boxing
as vauxhall astra because we wouldn't
like to smoke in the rooms because we
were so desperately like this is too
this is rock and roll yeah and then when
the tour started getting bigger like
when we started doing europe and stuff
like we were going from city to city to
city to city to city every night but
after each show we would go out and get
drunk because we wanted to drink because
we always thought it was going to be
over we couldn't believe that we were
getting in lithuania or poland or
estonia or any of these places
uh
and so we'd drink until three in the
morning and then get on the plane the
next day fly to the next place and
because that new place is so exciting to
see you as well there they want to go
out as well and we were just like okay i
guess we're just going out and we're
going to do this because we might not
ever get to do this tour again and then
that tour happened seven more times and
now i'm an alcoholic and that's how it
gets here
and now you're going to america tomorrow
yeah tomorrow yeah yeah
uh and this will be
uh
[Music]
i mean after this one because of the way
the tour has been and because of how i
handle things during the pandemic like
i'm making one of those vows to myself
where i'm gonna be after this tour is
done
uh and once i get back from america
that's me going
sober for a bit why after this tour why
not for this tour
because that would be
that's not a realistic goal
that is not a
man i'm going back to america do you do
you know how many british comedians have
cracked america
it's like four
it's like you know
uh i'm then it's
like to this day i can't believe that i
get to you know how many days you go
uh 47 no no no no no no sorry wait for
52 days and i think it's like 35 shows
that's disgusting yeah uh and it's you
know my mom when we're doing like real
like we're doing the beacon theater
we're doing the orphee and we're doing
the wilbur twice like we're doing
theaters that like when i was growing up
watching
uh stand up and then consuming stand-up
like these are the venues that ev like
all the big dogs [ __ ] performed at so
to be
doing a tour actually playing and
selling out at those venues i'm like i'm
not doing i'm not not
doing that to the way i think it should
be done and the way i think that should
be done is enjoying every second of it
not saying no to [ __ ] anything we've
got a tour manager again
like it's his job to drive us places
and
i know i i don't know big big shout out
to ed neil my tour manager like he he
enjoys it too because man we're not
we're not like [ __ ] we're not meth
heads we're not doing coke every [ __ ]
night or heroin like we're just we like
drinking and we like marijuana
and
you know uh we've we haven't been able
to tour america in two years
uh it's genuinely despite america's deep
deep problems with literally everything
i think they are some of the most
commonly intelligent audiences in the
world because they
they just they they've had their type of
comedy of storytellers that's been there
they're
very commonly illiterate and that's why
they're fun to perform it's only the man
there's comedy clubs in every single
[ __ ] state and good ones and several
ones like it's
comedy's been part of the stand up
comedy especially has probably existed
in america i'd say the longest at least
in its current form what's an american
audience like compared with the british
one
a bit more shitty
[Laughter]
um
they are i mean they're more they're
scarier to
offend like a british person will write
a letter an american will kick your head
and outside
uh you know americans you know they take
things
when they when they
do take things personally taking it
personally is a has brave consequences
yeah um they are much more high energy
like the one of the things i really find
fascinating about american audiences
is
uh
the american confidence is something
that just doesn't exist in the world and
like america even
unconfident americans who tell you that
aren't confident are still some of the
most confident people
americans are so violently themselves so
like they they don't they're just so 110
american all of the time like i've i've
i've never like even introverted
americans like i'm introverted and
you're like buddy you ain't like the
[ __ ] are you talking about
uh but that confidence in an audience is
unbelievable because if you're doing a
gig in
let's say like a sensitive part of the
england london right you're doing a gig
in london
you do a risque joke about whatever if
there are
uh 50 of the audience that like that
joke right another 50 don't that 50 that
do like are not going to laugh because
british people like laughing as groups
like a lot of audiences we're going okay
oh no it's part of the [ __ ] status
quo and i don't want to [ __ ] stand
out here because i don't want to have to
you know defend my decision to laugh
here and i'm not confident enough to be
the one laughing alone every american
has the confidence to laugh alone they
couldn't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] like after
i've been at comedy clubs where there's
300 people in a room and a comedian's on
stage and only seven people are enjoying
that comedian but [ __ ] hell those
seven are enjoying that comedian and
they'll make it known
they'll clap they'll [ __ ] cheer
they'll say hell yeah whoa all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that the americans do as an
audience you're not a fan of the woo
though i hate it i think it's the most
disruptive uh thing in the entire world
uh for comedy is timing
like that's the comedy's all about
[ __ ] timing and a woo is just a like
a ric flair heckle this isn't you
helping the show this is you
so desperate to be heard
so desperate like and and you're doing
it because you agree with something
ahead so it's virtue signaling in a way
like it's this like i say something you
go whoa you're like [ __ ] i don't
care if you agree i said it's my [ __ ]
never forget you all pay to look this
way and i get paid to look that way
that's the [ __ ] dynamic shut the [ __ ]
up
what about good friendships cause you
talk about that in the book right and
you talk about kai and tour manager and
stuff like that we got friends with
girls that you've been friends with for
years and what about principles of good
friendship and lessons that you've got
from that
um i i think it's you know i i would say
my friends will all tell you that i'm a
very very good friend uh i sometimes
feel like a bad friend because i'm
really bad at communication and staying
in contact with friends if you're in
front of me as my friend i'll talk to
you for hours and hours and hours until
you go but if one of my friends text me
hey how are you i'm like
ugh
what are you doing like let's like i'll
talk to you when i [ __ ] see you like
i travel i'm gonna be in my photo they
just you know messing you but i do like
my friends from high school uh and the
ones that do keep in contact with me
because
you know the friendships i've had the
longest and the people that have known
you the longest are very very good at
telling you when you're not being true
to yourself
like they're the ones that you know are
able to you know they're very supportive
at least my friends are but anytime i've
stepped out of line or let my ego's gone
too [ __ ] big or they feel like i'm
going in a direction that's not me
they'll go oh decade because who i am
doesn't matter to them and then that's
absolutely the way it should be
like i am the only people that think
i'm
you know famous and important other
people that [ __ ] love me and you
should enjoy their opinions
but you should that shouldn't be what
you think of yourself it's the people
that have known you the
the longest and
i i think it's very very important to
have friends for
friends that you can trust to do
anything for you and who you would do
anything for but ones that are going to
be honest when you need them to be like
that's you know in a world of [ __ ]
lies and [ __ ] you need the people
that are willing to let you dead in the
eyes and go you're a [ __ ] now
and and and and and i've had that happen
a lot at different points in my life
from people i love being like you are
turning into a [ __ ] [ __ ] and every
time it made me take a big step back and
go okay like that heart don't get me
wrong that like that was a deep kick in
the [ __ ] balls there but you know you
wouldn't be saying it if it wasn't true
it's one of those things we've got a
loneliness pandemic or a loneliness
epidemic sort of sweeping the world at
the moment and it is it's one of those
things i'm surprised by some of the
comments that i see on youtube i did an
episode with john peterson and we talked
about um losing friends as you grow
older so as you grow up and you kind of
change and maybe people were with you
but you're not that person that they
were with anymore it's not that they
actually love the essence of you it's
that they loved
party dan or tv
or whatever the [ __ ] um and i was really
surprised in the comments because people
were saying a lot of people and this may
skew because youtube attracts people who
maybe spend more time on the internet
than they do with friends but
i was really surprised at how many
people said don't need friends like try
try to to work with other people i like
i'll make a go of it on my own i'm like
man like i understand the compulsion of
where that's coming from i genuinely do
like the world scorned you and you've
tried to make friends with people and it
hasn't worked and you now think right
[ __ ] that i'm not gonna bother i'm just
gonna keep
keep to myself and this is a safer
way to not get hurt
i'm just surprised i'm surprised by how
many people how many people have that
approach yeah and that man that saddens
me man like i
man i love my
uh
i love my friends and i wouldn't be the
person i am today without them like i
i'm terrified of the person i would be
if i was just given [ __ ] free range
and not
corrected and i'm not being corrected in
bad ways i'm not being hampered or you
know cut down but there's people that
know and want the best for me and when
i'm not acting with my because you'd
mind we like to think we know when we're
acting with our own in our own
self-interests but that's not how the
ego works and that's not how you know
we're not that at least i'm not that
[ __ ] intelligent that i don't know
when i'm self sabotaging or when i'm
being [ __ ] lazy or man on the other
side of things like man there was points
on this tour
during this tour now where i [ __ ]
hated the show
like because i've just done it too much
and i was just if i was being now that
i'm i'm past it i can be honest i was
getting just a bit lazy i was kind of
raining in a bit and we did some shows
in london and london is very sensitive
nowadays
and and and i i was [ __ ] hating the
show and i was just ranting about it to
anyone that would [ __ ] listen and it
was my friends that have known me for
several years and seen all my stuff that
were like okay cool like we're sad that
you're sad but this is a good show and
we know it better than you do at this
point like you're being illogical on the
other side of things it um
helps but man i'm very good at cutting
people out of my life too
like if there's somebody in my life who
i don't like it like just because we've
been friends for eight to nine years
like if you make such a turn in
personality that i can't see eye to eye
with you anymore and not just like on a
[ __ ] little political thing like i
i don't want to be one of those people
where man i don't agree with you
politically but we're still friends like
i i think it's politics is such a small
thing and
in the actual experience of life
uh to to do we blend over far more than
like what are your thoughts of fiscal
policy or where should we be at to do
with this type of like gun regulation or
some [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and i don't
really know i think it's important to
have [ __ ] feelings on those things
and and opinions and everything but for
me personally for who i am i i don't
really
care like i don't talk about i'll vote
and you'll vote and then that's what
will happen we're not going to change
each other's opinions realistically
but if there's something that's done
something reprehensible or i just think
they've become a shitty [ __ ] person
i can cut you out like that and feel and
the reason i can do that is because i've
got a bunch of other friends that's why
you need lots back obama yeah yeah you
were talking there about having lost a
little bit of love for one of the shows
that you did yeah so you're touring and
you did this with a bunch of different
shows you've done one of them what like
400 times or something or [ __ ]
we did it we know we did x i think was
yeah 300 uh performances disgusting
amount of times yeah yeah just yeah
didn't you mean about how do you
not
lose love
for the art form generally how do you
stop yourself from resenting comedy
wholesale because you're kind of you've
turned something that you love into a
labor
well that's it's it's about slowing it
down um like it's it's about
understanding that you know for so many
of years of my career it was all about
striking while the iron was hot because
it was like who knows when this is gonna
be over like i was given this
opportunity here and i'm really hot
right now i've gotta [ __ ] act on work
hard yeah yeah yeah and then that went
that way that led to this and another
iron strike and i've got to [ __ ] work
hard now i've got to capitalize on this
and so on and so forth and then the
reason that that 300 show two was such a
nightmare was just because it was after
netflix came out and everything blew up
and
and we were just constantly striking and
it turned into this 300 day tour and i
lost the love of the job and i resented
my audience which i never wanted to do
or get to that stage because that's just
such a stereotypical oh all of your
dreams came true and then you hated them
like oh [ __ ] you've really become that
[ __ ] like you're that old trope jesus
um
but
it's
i worked so many hot i worked so hard
for so many years so that i could
take the foot off the accelerator and
thankfully now my career is at a
position where i can just go all right
i'm established in
all continents apart from you know
antarctica old ones yeah yeah the cold
ones um i
do
you know
most territories um
i think the only people i'm second to
are like eddie izzard
um jimmy
uh cabrillo iglesias and bilbar
um
and
uh
my audience are great they're incredibly
loyal because i've managed to somehow
[ __ ] make something that went quite
cult and that's very cool
uh and now
it's slowing down it's just going man i
wanna i want to be able to do this show
many times because that's a touring has
always been the goal for me i love it
it's my favorite part that's what being
a comedian is is touring that's the job
i'm a road comic
uh
and but it's about making sure there's
gaps in between those tours and then
they're easy it doesn't have to be every
single day now like it can be i can take
two or three weeks off at a time then go
to australia do a month in australia
come back take a month off and then
start doing around the uk just so that
i've got time to be myself
and because it's not [ __ ] daniel
sloth stage comedian that comes up with
the jokes it's not him like he performs
what i think
but i've got to have [ __ ] time to
think uh to turn over stuff otherwise
i'm j if i'm working every day and i'm
being that heightened psychopath on
stage then that's not good and also a
man i drink on stage and because after
the show when you've got so much
adrenaline man it's really hard to go to
sleep for me without marijuana after a
show like
you know if a show ends at [ __ ] 11
and i'm meeting fans afterwards uh and
taking photos until about midnight
half 12
and and my flight's at 5am
without weeds
i'm not sleeping there's too much and
that's another fact that you have to
take in if i'm doing a big long tour i
know my health is going to [ __ ]
deteriorate because i don't have the
emotional maturity like yet to to not
feel like a [ __ ] rock star when i do
this and i know i shouldn't and i'm
working on it but that's the
you know this this tour is like the the
reason i'm allowing myself this america
tour to be everything i wanted to be
is because i i really do think this is
the last time i'll i'll i'll do it
like this because this is the post
covered one everyone's gonna be [ __ ]
excited to be out i'm excited to be out
and doing it uh and i'm just like just
[ __ ]
do it properly because after this i'm
definitely
considering
yeah yeah oh my i mean no because like i
mean you were an inspiration for it you
were sober for how long thousand days
yeah so i mean i'm not do that much
but all my friends there's another great
comedian called nick cody uh who went
sober for a year and he says it really
uh he said it was difficult but it
really helped well he said the first
month's difficult and then after that
it's a habit and it's just it's easy
like from that point once you get used
to not doing it you know
um and i've always fascinated like i
mean i know i drink a lot i mean i'm a
drug addict when it comes to marijuana
which isn't a bad thing to be
addicted to but it being anything isn't
[ __ ] great for kids what would be
harder to kick drinking or marijuana
marijuana really yeah yeah yeah yeah
definitely yeah um i can
i i like drinking on stage um
because
well for several reasons me i one of the
big ones i think it makes me look cool
like and every and um when i grew up and
i watched stand-up bill hex would smoke
on stage
ed barn would smoke on stage and i still
associate smoking with being [ __ ]
cool anytime i can smoke on stage i do
even if i don't smoke like if we're in
like russian venues or [ __ ] uh
bulgaria i'm like can i smoke on stage
like yeah we don't care i'll do it
really hard to time jokes and say that's
a different [ __ ] you'd think it would
just be easy but no really makes you
appreciate that del moran
and and and bill hicks were masters of
timing with all this
um
dylan moran drinking a bottle of wine on
stage that was always just so cool
what's he doing is he doing stand-up
still
yes yeah yeah uh he's
um oh he does that he does a lot of
acting nowadays yeah i knew he got huge
in a tv
um
and and and writing and stuff um but no
he still does stand up i mean i love
dylan moran
um so for me man i used to drink gin and
tonics on stage and uh that just felt
like a bit [ __ ]
widow way to me no like you know a gin
and tonic's a widow's drink
like it's something you drink on the
porch while you do a crossword and
remnants about your [ __ ] late husband
you know i i got into whiskey and i'm
like i'm i'm scottish
and and and it's it's a strong drink and
also it forces me to slow down you can't
like with a gin and tonic i could i
don't know and then it said you can't do
that with whiskey it's a real slow
[ __ ] drink
um
and yeah and it's part of the
it's part of the performance like it's
part of the illusion or the fear of like
the reason the reason you don't talk
while i'm talking
is because i've got so much to say that
i can afford to sit down pour myself a
whiskey drink it and you as an audience
will say [ __ ] nothing
where can people go if they need to get
tickets for the america tour uh just
daniels.com all the dates are up there
amazing and everyone you hate is going
to die will be linked in the show notes
below don't try and contact you on
social media because you know on there
nope i mean you could i mean you can um
my my agent will occasionally send me a
screenshot of a nice compliment
but i don't read many of my agent's
emails so it doesn't
good luck with the tour dude and i will
see you when you're back i definitely
might thank you love you too bud
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe makes me very
happy indeed
peace
you